hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
it's the 28th of April and a show you're
watching is gamespot news head of Xbox
and all-round swell dude Phil Spencer
said that Microsoft are planning to
shake things up for the Xbox III
conference this year responding to a fan
query on Twitter regarding the
publishers III plans Spencer said that
they would have quote some interesting
changes this year for the briefing and
the week adding I like it when we test
ourselves to do better each year Spencer
clarified that Microsoft are going to
talk about games for both the xbox one
and pc this year whereas they usually
only tends toward the former their dual
focus makes sense given the launch of
windows 10 this summer which is going to
incorporate an Xbox app and support for
cross-platform play it came it upset
everybody and it went so it's been the
story for valves paid mods on Steam the
company have backtracked on the
controversial plan just days after
launching it they'll released a
statement across the Steam Workshop and
reddit concerning the retraction which
read we've done this because it's clear
we didn't understand exactly what we
were doing they'll have promised full
refunds to anyone who spent money on any
Skyrim mods in the short time they were
available valve explained they were
hoping to enable mod makers to work on
their creations full-time but admitted
that while they have found success
applying this feature to their own games
like dota 2 and tf2 third-party games
with pre-established mod communities are
another beast entirely finally the
president of daybreak games have said
that world of warcraft style MMOs are
dead as far as the modern gaming
landscape is concerned John Smedley who
heads up the studio formerly known as
Sony Online Entertainment explained that
while day breaks new zombie game h1z1 is
an MMO he thinks it's better described
as quote a session based online game
with a lot of people smedley explains
that the average play time in h one dead
one is 45 minutes and proclaimed that
quote that's what today's game is want
here
test of the audience are no longer
committing long periods of time to
gaming like they did in well and
EverQuest let me know down in the
comment how much time a week you commit
to gaming and if you think games with
big time commitments are going to die
out you can head to gain spot we've got
stories on the announcement of five
nights at Freddy's 4 and final fantasy
15 skipping III that is everything I
wanted to tell you about today do let me
know what you think down in that comment
box and I'll catch you again tomorrow